bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sport l'émission
consacrée à l'actualité et l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite on passe au sommaire course à pied
la course royal était organisée ce
dimanche dans les allées du château de
versailles
des milliers de coureurs ont participé à
cette épreuve de 15 km les détails dans
cette édition
en bas les féminines de
montigny-le-bretonneux montrons
nationale une la saison prochaine pour
débriefer cet exploit nous avons déjà en
plateau toute l'équipe de montigné
breton et le coach philippe étrange
cyclisme sur piste le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines propose
désormais des baptêmes encadrés par les
pisteurs de l'équipe de france plus
d'informations à suivre
et puis enfin l'émission comme tous les
lundis nous ferons un point complet sur
les résultats sportifs du week-end dans
le département nous parlerons du nouveau
skate park de montier retenue et de
rugby avec l'association caritatif 7 de
coeur organisé à versailles
c'est sûrement l'une des courses les
plus belles de france la course royal de
versailles était programmé ce dimanche
matin au total plus de 14 mille coureurs
ont pris le départ de cette épreuve de
15 km organisées dans les allées du
château
le montage est signée roma respini
associe la course à pied un cadre
somptueux c'est la recette gagnante de
la course royal de versailles
pour sa quatrième édition l'événement
une nouvelle fois attiré plus de 14000
runner dans les jardins du château
une fréquentation qui a été multiplié
par deux depuis la création de l'épreuve
tous les ans ça monte ça monte c'est une
course qui vraiment commence à
s'installer dans le paysage des vraies
courses à la fois en ile-de-france et en
france cette course de 15 km attire à la
fois des amoureux du château et des
coureurs confirmés et de couleurs très
sérieux qui viennent il ya vraiment un
satellite en plus à l'avantagé que c'est
vraiment un parcours dans lesquels
justement les gens s'entraînent tout au
long de l'année et c'est pas un parcours
simplement d'agrément il ya des gens qui
font ça à l'agrément parce qu'il regarde
il ya des gens qui ne regardent
absolument pas le paysage et qui sont là
pour faire un vrai temps
la particularité de cette épreuve le
terrain la course royal se déroule sur
du bitume de la pelouse mais également
sur du pavé ça a beaucoup changé par
rapport à l'année dernière
donc c'était un pull sur la il y avait
beaucoup plus de victimes un petit peu
des passages en forêt mais l'essence est
un très beau parcours et une quatrième
fois c'est un peu atypiques comme course
déjà le fait de courir dans les allées
du parc du château de versailles
et puis c'est vrai que c'est très varié
et non pas sur des pavés sur la route
sur sur la terre de l'herbe
il ya beaucoup de virages beaucoup de
relances donc voilà c'est un parcours
très varié en une boucle ce qui est
assez appréciable de faire une bourde
tout simplement sur un 15 km chez les
hommes julien bartoli a remporté la
compétition pour la deuxième année
consécutive en cinquante et une minutes
et 40 secondes et a devancé de près
d'une minute second pierre et qui marche
chez les femmes florence erpelding s'est
imposé en 58 minutes et 8 secondes homme
incroyable exploit des féminines de
montigny-le-bretonneux les joueuses de
philippe l'étrange qualifiant barrage
suite au retrait du havre se sont
imposés en match décisif contre nîmes à
villefranche à villefranche sur saône
près de lyon les ihm antennes ont dominé
leurs adversaires sur le score de 30 à
26 conséquence elle monte en nationale
une une première depuis dix ans pour
nous parler de cette montée nous
recevons sur ce plateau toute l'équipe
nous allons présenter tout le monde je
commence par vous philippe étrange vous
êtes le coach de l'équipe
bonsoir bonsoir à votre droite vous avez
les jambes fanny jean baptiste qui est
donc ailière droite dans l'équipe de mon
team retenu de le côté philippe agostini
responsable du secteur sportif et avant
tout à ses pivots de montigny on va
également faire un tour de table donc je
commence par vous jean pierre jean
pierre delwart d'achat voilà moi je fais
un peu l'intendance et je suis surtout
chronométreur à domicile ou secrétaire à
l'extérieur je fais la table de marque
d'accord passé le micro votre rue
voisine
moi c'est marine robben et je suis leur
gauche gabriel par mr aller à gauche
également pauline bigot et pivot donc on
passe de côté ces méga jeu le demi
centre ailière gauche deschamps diane
demi centre
bonjour je suis clélia et je joue sur
les postes d'arrière et loubet désirez
un coach donc on voit philippe étrange
qui a beaucoup de sourires sur sur ce
plateau
cette victoire à l'oeuf énormément bien
cette montée fait énormément de bien oui
oui c'est surtout qu'elle était une
expérien moment donné donc on a saisi
notre chance avec avec réussite
justement avant de plonger dans
l'analyse du match on revient sur sur ce
conte de fées on peut appeler ça comme
ça il faut rappeler que vous avez
terminé la saison à la troisième place
du classement donc par conséquent vous
n'étiez pas qualifié pour les barrages
et finalement suite au retrait du havre
vous avez été donc qualifiés justement
ce qu'on va dire que sow surclassement
vous y attendiez enfin si ça se fait
comme en fait expliqué il l'avait pensé
peut-être très fort et puis lors d'un
moment difficile de l'année on a dit bon
il faut absolument terminer troisièmes
pour pour essayer espérer
malheureusement que le haf décembre de
l'efsf h donc c'est ce qui s'est passé
donc la réserve ne pouvait pas prétendre
aux barrages
vous espérez quand même avoir cette
façon barham a vu les résultats dû
avouer on espère un petit peu et quelle
a été votre première réaction
philippe amagou quand vous avez appris
ça la victoire oui nous laquelle jean
laville à cette qualification
surpris non parce qu'on l'avait comme
l'a dit philippe un petit peu un petit
peu espéré anticipée ou pas par le dire
comme ça mais bon c'était mis en
position justement de d'avoir cette
troisième place au cas où
et après pouvoir bénéficier de
l'opportunité et de conclure lors du
match de barrage les plus étranges vous
l'avez su quand même temps environ à
avancer sur mansion une semaine
officiellement une semaine
est-ce que vous avez le temps justement
fanny jean baptiste de préparer au mieux
ce match on a eu une semaine pour le
préparer pas suffisant ah non vous parce
qu'on était plutôt sur une fin de saison
et on pensait que les barrages c'est à
oublier final on l'a préparé comme on a
pu sur une semaine et ça a suffi vu le
résultat
amandine via c7 justement se remettre
dans la compétition c'est pas ce pas
trop dur justement de se remettre dedans
se dire finalement là plus rien à jouer
et d'un seul coup de voir jouer un match
décisif peut être l'un des matches les
plus décisifs de l'histoire du club mais
c'est vrai que c'est jamais évident mais
après on n'avait pas non plus arrêter
des entraînements même si on avait un
peu diminué le rythme donc je pense que
on s'y attendait pas forcément mais dans
ces cas là il n'y a pas vraiment besoin
de préparation s'est appréciée dans la
tête et puis ça c'est ça s'est vu sur le
terrain
donc ils ont bâti ce n'est pas trop
compliqué à psychologiquement se
remettre dans le bain terme est dans le
vin oui ça l'a été en début de match
peut-être mais non savait qu'il fallait
fallait y aller fallait tout donné donc
on a fait ce qu'on a pu
philippe l'étrange comment on fait pour
continuer à garder justement cet esprit
de compétition quand on est coach quand
on sait qu'il y ait rien à jouer
finalement on n'a rien lâché on s'est
même à la fin du championnat centre et
nick deux fois mais c'était deux fois
c'est assez riche par semaine et puis
bon en attendant le dernier résultat du
havre qui nous a permis de faire ces
barrages donc voilà on savait qu'en face
on avait nîmes c'était soit le havre
soit nous donc savait que c'était une
équipe jeune donc on a un peu travaillé
dans ce sens mais justement on va parler
de ce match contre nîmes
est ce que c'était un adversaire que
vous connaissez bien un flip l'étrange
pas ou pas du tout s'ils ont déjà ou
jamais dans cette poule là avec les fils
du sud 2 e s du sud est donc par contre
on savait qu'elle était jeune c'est un
centre de formation donc un peu
peut-être stéréotypé pour elle l'avenir
donc voilà ça allait laisser s'énerver
pour pardon pour pour passer devant et
du coup comment on prépare ce type de
match philippe l'étrange c'est c'est
vraiment se concentrer sur notre équipe
en fait sur le type de montigné avant de
penser à l'adversaire je pense que non
plus où on s'est plus concentré sur nous
il fallait faire notre handball pour
espérer faire quelque chose si c'est ce
qui c'est passé puis pas si la
préparation du match est ce que vous
vous avez mis la pression jose alors en
leur disant il faut absolument gagner il
faut absolument monter en nationale une
vous avez vous signé plus tôt tempérant
disant bon bah finalement c'est du bonus
or c'est un projet déjà qu'on mûrit
depuis qu'on a mis en place depuis
quatre ans au club d'accéder à la
nationale 1 c'était un peu prévu pas
trop cette année c'était plutôt prévues
la saison prochaine
maintenant quand l'opportunité s'est
présentée il n'y a pas de pression à
mettre au fish pourrait que partir
demain on peut accéder à cette division
qui est la plus haute division amateur
national c'est la 3e 3e niveau national
je crois qu'il ya pas de pression à
mettre un tout le monde est dans le
projet c'est un projet qui est et qui
étaient entendus qui était convenu avec
les filles c'est un vrai projet sportif
pour le club et pour elle je pense qu'il
ya pas beaucoup de pression à m je crois
que tout le monde est parti bien motivés
pour pour atteindre cet objectif et donc
même pas un petit discours juste avant
d'avoir fait un petit discours on va
dire rapide mais je crois que c'était un
peu aussi pour des d'armes pour
dédramatiser un petit peu même si on ne
pensait pas l'échec non vous n'a pas non
plus le l'occulté de conforter les
filles sur le match c'était un match
très important à la fois pour elle à la
fois pour le club mais il n'y avait pas
donné pas de drame et avait oui un peu
de motivation supplémentaire mais je
crois qu'elles ont pas eu besoin de
s'annoncer était bien de bien dans le
projet bien dans le bien dans le match
avant le déplacement s'est passé c'est
assez tranquillement et puis tout le
monde s'est concentrée au fur à mesure
de la proche du match s'est mis dans le
match
après bon le déroulement du match un
petit peu compliqué au début mais après
tout le monde a bien compris le
l'objectif est le et vous étiez comment
psychologiquement les jeux on va passer
le micro à gabriel parloir vous vous
étiez vous étiez comment du coup avant
de préparer ce match psychologiquement
vous êtes lancés dans ce match comme en
jour du match le jour du match mais en
fait c'est quitte ou double donc faut
pas avoir de regret faut vraiment tout
donner parce que l'issue en fait ça
passe ou ça casse toi donc tout donner
et ne rien regretter c'était surtout ça
que la défaite soit là ou pas
l'essentiel c'était de ne pas avoir de
regret on en a pas eu et qui plus est on
a gagné
philippe l'étrange vous avez remporté ce
match 30 à 26 finalement c'est quand
même un score assez serré est ce que
vous attendiez à ce type de match
oh bien sûr il ne pensait pas gagner de
15 buts
donc on sait que tout jeu toujours ces
matches là c'est très très serré il ya
des temps forts des on espère que les
temps faibles soient peu nombreux et
papa l'ont donc voila vous me disais que
l'équipe vous la connaissez pas
forcément très bien c'est de ne voir pas
du tout vous à vous étiez surpris de son
niveau ou est ce que vous attendiez à
peu près à ça non s'attendait un peu à
peu près à ça si ce n'est on s'attendait
à voir un peu plus des plus grandes
parce qu'on avait joué le havre nous qui
était la même configuration que nîmes
qui avait des joueuses beaucoup plus
grande et c est en fin de compte nîmes
c'était des petits gabarits qui qui
jouait vite on a failli jean baptiste ce
match vous l'avez remporté aussi grâce à
votre talent offensif on vous avez
marque fin mai mme carole mittelheisser
marqué 10 buts ou amandine va si vous
avez marqué six buts
est ce que finalement c'est la réussite
offensive qui a fait la différence dans
ce match
je pense que c'est la réussite offensive
oui sur la garde est peut-être là la fin
du match mais c'est surtout l'expérience
qui nous a fait gagner parce que en face
on était face à des joueuses
relativement jeune qui avait de
l'expérience certes mais qui cavale est
plus que qu'ils réfléchissaient certes
mais qui avait tendance à beaucoup
courir et à jouer assez rapidement nous
on a essayé de tempérer de de réfléchir
à ce qu'on allait faire pour pouvoir
conserver le ballon et puis à les mettre
au fond quoi amandine passé vous avez
marqué six buts lors de cette rencontre
c'est finalement un travail un travail
d'équipé cette victoire où c'est
vraiment sur quelques individualités que
ça c'est ça s'est opposé à non feinte
c'est tout complètement un travail
d'équipé
en plus surtout pour mon poste je
dépends complètement des autres joueuses
après c'est vrai que carroll a fait un
super match au barrage mais je pense que
c'est une victoire d'équipé avant tout
et tout le monde a mis du sien et
personne n'a rien à se reprocher sur ce
match là en tout cas on était toutes
avec le même objectif et voilà j'ai été
tout autant motivé les unes que les
autres
le résultat est là amandine passer ce
match au moment où il ya le coup de
sifflet final
il se passe quoi dans votre tête plein
de choses près n'importe quoi voilà on
voit tout le monde saute et par tous
pleuré et crié allah tout le monde saute
dans les bras je me rappelle de philippe
à moitié sur le terrain déjà depuis au
moins 5 minutes
ah non c'était un bon moment et vous
allez célébrer votre victoire d'une
drôle de façon on regarde justement un
extrait
amandine va cesser c'est quoi exactement
7 cette danse a été improvisée sur le
moment c'est dans l'intégration des
nouvelles en fait en début de saison
alors les aime bien tomber par terre
puis nous ça nous fait plaisir aussi
plus donc voila c'était le l'occasion de
marquer le coup et elle parle mais on
voit qu'il ya quand même une bonne
osmose dans ce groupe on voit que le
groupe vit bien vous faire vous
ressentez comment ce groupe c'est un
groupe qui a de l'avenir justement ce
qu'il est cohérent il laisse ou des
biens qui se renouvelle d'année en année
après de l'avenir forcément puisqu'il ya
des jeunes et il ya du talent des filles
qui qui ont pas encore explosé donc très
il ya des anciennes qui partiront aussi
ça va se renouveler petit à petit mais
oui moi j'ai confiance en ce groupe
après l'année prochaine ne sera pas
facile on passe un cap et c'est là que
le groupe va devoir se montrer solide
et unis parce que je pense que ça sera
loin d'être facile à chaque samedi et
dans le groupe qui met le plus ambiance
et royal qui me lis dans l'os c'est un
peu comme une grande famille finalement
oui généralement oui après il ya c'est
vrai qu'il ya des initiales à chacun son
petit truc
la petite blague l'idée de conneries on
en fasse maintenant tout le monde
bref tout le monde joue le jeu en fait
y'a pas de ce que dans le vestiaire
reste dans le vestiaire ce qui est dans
le car est dans le car donc c'est notre
petit secret on revient la compétition
donc montigny désormais donc en
nationale une
est ce que le groupe vous satisfait pour
cette montée en nationale une et ce
qu'il faudra peut-être corriger
certaines choses philippe étrange
apporter des idées nouvelles joueuses à
maturité peut-être oui bientôt on est
sûr quelques quelques filles y en a déjà
une qu'à signer là une demi centre et
puis on est sur une arrière et une
ailière pour les filles qui ont déjà
joué à ce niveau là pour justement
renforcer le groupe et piller a apporté
aussi aider les jeunes à avoir un peu
plus de maturité petit à petit pour
l'avenir et à ce que l'année prochaine
se fera avec vous comme coach
ils devront normalement une romance oui
énormément
et justement est ce que le groupe est ce
que le projet ou satisfaits ce que vous
voulez continuer dans cette voie du coup
bien sûr c'est que quand j'ai aimé
montigny je commence à l'aimer ça fait
pas longtemps que je suis là je suis
venu pour les jeunes je me suis retrouvé
avec des vieilles entre guillemets voilà
donc tu prends une rue je commence à
l'aimer
après il ya des tensions mais ça fait
partie de la vie du de l'équipe et c'est
jamais toujours très facile savamment
après faut les régler et puis part de
mon pied puis j'ai pas de souci merci à
vous philippe l'étrange merci à toute
l'équipe d'être passé sur ce plateau on
continuera à vous suivre évidemment
l'année prochaine en nationale une bon
courage et pourquoi pas monter encore
d'un étage
l'année prochaine pourquoi pas
on passe on passe maintenant cyclisme
direction le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines veut surfer
sur les derniers championnats du monde
de cyclisme sur piste et sur les très
bons résultats de l'équipe de france
pour cela des baptêmes sur piste avec
des professionnels des champions
français sont maintenant programmée dans
l'enceinte sportive romain sauce fini
pour le montage tout est une question
d'anticipation
on peut pas s'arrêter en moins de deux
ans en freinant super fort il faut
quelques c'est pour ça que nous par
exemple après les sprints on met trois
quatre tours avant de s'arrêter parce
que ben on laisse décéléré le vélo et on
profite de la piste pour essayer de
freiner un peu en montant sans nous
faire à l'ancien coach de luxe pour ces
cyclistes quentin lafargue médaillé de
bronze sur la vitesse individuelle lors
des derniers championnats du monde est
là pour guider les débutants pendant
leur baptême sur la piste du vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ce qui m'a attiré c'est fait de pouvoir
essayer de transmettre un petit peu et
puis rentrer en contact avec d'autres
gens qui nous fait on connaît tellement
ce conte
ce qu'on fait tous les jours que
moi j'aime bien faire ça difficile après
c'est sûr que on n'a pas forcément les
mots facile au début c'est à dire qu'on
emploie peut-être d'un vocabulaire un
peu technique dans un premier temps mais
pour faire un vieux on arrive à faire en
sorte que tout le monde comprenne
aujourd'hui une dizaine de novices est
venu tester la piste pour la toute
première fois
le fait de me dire je râle et pied
accroché à la mais apparemment il
paraît que c'est plus sécurisé que
sécurisant que nous pouvons avoir
depuis son inauguration en janvier 2014
le vélodrome accueilli 4312 baptême
l'apprentissage se fait en douceur pour
éviter les accidents on les fait monter
progressivement on l'a fait mais après
sur la piste en effet monté que dans les
lignes droites s'adapter au pignon fixe
aux pédales automatiques quelques tours
de réglages dans les routes un médaillé
et les progrès sont déjà là je trouve
que c'est
en suivant les conseils ces exercices
simples
j'espère que ça mais je pensais
génial franchement si j'ai des
sensations de vitesse sensation d'être
en extérieur c'est rigolo frustration
d'être pris au vent
ça c'est d'être amusant de voir le
plancher qui tourne si peu d'importance
en bande sera piste mais l'important
c'est super sur les 300 abonnés que
compte aujourd'hui le vélodrome sans
découvert la piste grâce au baptême
il suffit juste de se lancer si vous
voulez tester la piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le baptême
coûte 18 euros après le cyclisme en
passe maintenant coup de projecteur
maintenant sur le skatepark de
montigny-le-bretonneux
c'est officiel la ville de montigny le
bretonneux vient d'inaugurer son tout
nouveau skatepark les nouvelles
infrastructures donc ont été inaugurés
au complexe sportif pierre de coubertin
les riders peuvent désormais défier la
gravité sur de nouveaux blocs et sur une
nouvelle surface patrick jacques de
dixmude pour les images une cure de
jouvence pour le skate park de
montigny-le-bretonneux créé en 1999 au
complexe sportif pierre de coubertin
l'infrastructure a été totalement
modernisé pour un coût de 100 mille
euros de nouveaux blocs des nouvelles
rampante été installés objectif répondre
aux exigences des riders et leur offrir
les meilleures sensations possible c'est
une demande qui venait des jeunes déjà
il devenait un petit peu dangereux parce
qu'il s'était abîmé donc c'est pour ça
aussi qu'il était temps de faire quelque
chose
les jeunes les l'utiliser mais
maintenant il y avait de moins en moins
de jeunes qui utilisaient parce qu'il
devenait un petit peu vétuste
aujourd'hui la structure rivalise avec
les meilleurs skatepark d'île de france
la nouvelle surface de roulement permet
notamment d'aller plus vite et plus haut
elle est surtout moins dangereuse sur
l'ancienne structure les roues se
bloquer sur le métal avec l'humidité les
inconvénients qui appartiennent
maintenant au passé ces sportifs de
l'extrême en skate de trottinette ou
vélos peuvent désormais profiter
pleinement des sensations ça fait du
bien et les neuf parce qu'avant c'est
sûr qu'il était un peu et en mauvais
état et se sent pas de venir ici parce
que ça change comparé à ce qu'on avait
avant quand même
c'est vachement mieux que toutes
surfaces ému après même le sol est mieux
chez nous va si vous voulez vous offrir
des doses d'adrénaline le skate parc est
ouvert tous les jours jusqu'à 20 heures
on passe maintenant résultats sportifs
du week-end dans le département on
commence cette page résultats par du
football féminin l'équipe de france
féminine s'est brillamment qualifié pour
les quarts de finale de la coupe du
monde au canada
les bleus sont venus à bout de la corée
du sud en huitième le premier but a été
marqué par l'attaquant du paris saint
germain marie laure délie dès la 4e
minute de jeu après une belle passe de
sa coéquipière parisienne leur boulot
elodie thomis ensuite corsé l'addition
enfin marie laure délie a inscrit un
doublé en seconde période pour mettre
habré à l'abri les françaises score
final 3 buts à 0 les joueurs coachés par
philippe bergeron retrouvons les
allemandes au prochain tour une équipe
qui a marqué 19 buts en 4 matches en
baseball les cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux jeunes n'ont fait
qu'une bouchée de rennes lors de la 9e
journée de deuxième division
désigné mon teint se sont largement
imposés sur leur terrain sur le score de
10 1 dans la première manche et de 15 à
10 ans la seconde au classement montigny
remonte à la troisième place de ce
championnat avec un total de huit
victoires en 15 matches disputés pour
conserver sa place sur le podium
l'équipe devra gagner au moins un match
lors de son déplacement à clermont
ferrand
dimanche prochain on passe au rugby le
tournoi 7 de coeur étaient programmées
tout au long du week-end au stade
georges fontaine de versailles
l'objectif de cet événement amical était
de récolter des dons au profit de
l'association
au total trente équipes étaient
présentes pour ce grand rendez vous il y
avait notamment les sept salopards les
toons haven où les sept mains c'est donc
vous font peut-être sourire mais ce sont
les meilleurs joueurs français et
étrangers de rugby à 7
on écoute l'organisateur du tournoi 7 de
coeur benoît moreau il était au micro de
florennes par ferries
le niveau d'eau balla derrière moi il ya
deux joueurs qui jouent en pro d2 par
exemple
et en fait des joueurs de fédérale une
donc c'est un niveau qui est plus que
convenable
les équipes étrangères en relève le
niveau et je joue tous à un très haut
niveau et ça permet d'avoir un spectacle
très agréable alors la particularité d
autres biassette c'est qu'on sait que
c'est très lisible est très
compréhensible de tous et qui a pas
besoin d'être un expert du rugby pour
venir et profiter du spectacle
du côté des résultats les galactiques
seven ont remporté la coupe en battant
en finale et chevrotine timbale sur le
score de 40 à 5 toujours en rugby mais
cette fois ci dans la catégorie cadets
et en rugby à 15 l'équipe du sky rugby
et n'a pas créé la sensation en finale
de la coupe de france et saint
quentinois se sont lourdement inclinés
sur le score de 44 à 7 face au rugby
club du plateau briard ce dimanche à
viry-châtillon dépassé dès le début de
la rencontre les joueurs du sky n'ont
rien pu faire pour contenir les assauts
de leurs adversaires ils retenteront
leur chance l'année prochaine avec plus
d'expérience enfin il y avait du tir à
l'arc ce week-end à guyancourt avec le
fameux tir du roy une soixantaine de
personnes a participé à la compétition
dans la catégorie poussins c'est justin
mail qui a remporté l'épreuve chez les
adultes il a fallu six haltes pour que
damien berry remporté la compétition
avec son arc à poulies une nouvelle
édition de ce tir du roy et déjà
programmée pour juin prochain
en aviron le versailles et thomas baruch
a une nouvelle fois brillé avec ses
coéquipiers du quatre sans barreur poids
léger français ils en ont remporté la
médaille de bronze lors de la seconde
étape de la coupe du monde d'aviron qui
se déroule à varèse en italie
ils ont terminé derrière les néo
zélandais les suisses prochaine étape le
10 11 et 12 juillet à lucerne 1 on
termine ce magazine par l'agenda sportif
du week-end il y aura du taekwondo un
art martial d'origine sud coréenne ce
samedi à guyancourt l'open des yvelines
est organisé au gymnase de l'aviation de
16h30 à 21h avec des remises de
récompenses à la fin une centaine de
combattants est attendue pour cette
grande manifestation si vous voulez
assister à ce grand rendez vous l'entrée
est libre
et puis toujours à guyancourt un tournoi
de pétanque est programmée ce samedi de
13h à 22h au centre sportif les trois
mousquetaires les meilleurs tireurs et
pointeurs locaux seront présents pour
cette étape saint-quentinoise
le tournoi est organisé en coproduction
avec la pétanque que lui en courtoise
c'est la fin de ce set 8 sport merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive le très belle soirée sur tv fil